[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
el colapso de la economía en los países
de centroamérica en 'números rojos' por
la pandemia de kobe 19 empujan a
familias completas a emigrar hacia eeuu
aunque el éxodo estuvo en pausa por
algunos meses por las restricciones de
movimiento en respuesta al virus
la migración volvió a activarse y
mientras algunos viajan hacia el norte
en busca del sueño americano los que
están en méxico desde hace meses dicen
estar desesperados porque la pandemia
demora aún más la respuesta a sus
solicitudes de asilo las protestas
estallaron en la frontera después de que
la administración trump anunciara nuevas
reglas para negar el asilo con las
elecciones de eeuu de fondo la migración
volvió a convertirse en un tema político
[Aplausos]
cansados de la espera un grupo de
migrantes y activistas exigieron
respuestas llevan meses buscando que las
autoridades migratorias estadounidenses
contestan sus solicitudes de refugio la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 y las medidas
restrictivas del gobierno estadounidense
en las fronteras retrasa aún más sus
pedidos de asilo nosotros le pedimos
allá al otro lado valor de inmigración
es el presidente que por favor nos abra
la frontera y no tienen la oportunidad
de entrar a por mis hijos le pido por
mis hijos pues porque ellos tienen
derecho de estar en un lugar seguro
porque venimos de una porque no podemos
estar a jan y aunque lograron salir de
sus países aún están lejos de eeuu los
migrantes son obligados a vivir en
méxico mientras sus solicitudes de asilo
son examinadas al otro lado de la
frontera y lo difícil de la situación
estar aquí aquí todo el dolarizado uno
trabaja y gana 1750 pesos en un lado
pero
agua
gato médico por ejemplo soy hipertensa y
tengo que confiar me un medicamento
porque lo hace con las ciudades en el
lado mexicano desbordadas los
solicitantes de asilo deben seguir allí
el gobierno de eeuu y el mexicano
pactaron un polémico programa conocido
como permanecer en mexico se trata de
una medida que envía a los migrantes que
no son mexicanos a ciudades de ese país
mientras se celebran las audiencias de
sus casos en tribunales migratorios
estadounidenses
muchos de ellos llevan aquí meses o
incluso más de un año esperando y desde
la pandemia está cerrada completamente
la frontera para ellos y están como en
un limbo legal no saben cuándo va a ser
su siguiente audiencia no tienen ninguna
protección por parte de méxico o eeuu y
creo que muchos están luchando apenas
por tener que comer pero les afecta en
todo incluyendo la salud mental la corte
suprema de eeuu se comprometió a revisar
la legalidad de la política permanecer
en méxico pero mientras tanto los
solicitantes de refugio seguirán parados
en un país que no es el suyo ni tampoco
es al que sueñan emigrar
según la organización espacio migrante
en tijuana y 9000 personas que esperan
respuesta a sus solicitudes de refugio y
al menos 68 mil en otras ciudades a lo
largo de la frontera una cifra que crece
al tiempo que avanzan nuevas
movilizaciones de migrantes hacia eeuu
camino a eeuu estos migrantes
centroamericanos descansan cerca de las
vías del tren lograron llegar a veracruz
después de evadir los controles
fronterizos en guatemala en mexico ahora
esperan poder avanzar más rápido a bordo
de uno de estos vagones
la mayoría aquí son hondureños y miran
por las malas condiciones en su país
de hambre por ese camino chiquito
tatiana de crecer y ser recién nacido
está corriendo pues luego vienen las
mujeres también lo que necesita la
migración corretean los policías
y este grupo hace parte de la caravana
que partió de san pedro sula en
septiembre pasado los controles de
movimiento en las fronteras por el cob y
19 mantuvieron la migración en masa y el
norte bajo un aparente pausa sin embargo
la reapertura de los cruces impulsó a
cientos de centroamericanos a retomar el
viaje el presidente
claro nos sale porque no hay para dónde
acudir
no sale para ver nuestro país la pobreza
y la violencia tienen al límite a los
hondureños y la pandemia aumenta la
crisis en el país el banco central de
honduras prevé que la economía se
contraerá entre un 7 y un 8 por ciento
este año lo que significaría el peor
colapso financiero en la historia
mientras la presión aumenta en los
países centroamericanos por la crisis
los controles de movimiento por la
región son mucho más estrictos y la
migración toma un papel importante en la
campaña presidencial en eeuu y el dato
de emigración de la semana
más de 10.000 migrantes han llegado a
las islas canarias en españa durante el
2020 una cifra que se reporta cuando
faltan aún dos meses para el término del
año el dato convierte al 2020 en el
tercero con más arribos de inmigrantes
en embarcaciones precarias en la
historia de la isla
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
siga conectado con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]